the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
as you all know i have been making
videos on every chapter from a song of
ice and fire
now you will know what happens in the
books even if you haven't read them
yourself
in this chapter we finally leave
westeros as we make our way across the
sea to one of the free cities of essos
this is when we get our introduction to
daenerys targaryen
since i will mostly focus on house
targaryen in this video i figured this
would be a great opportunity for me to
announce some of the videos i will be
making in the future
now that we are only about a year and a
half away from hbo releasing house of
the dragon i need to start making videos
on
some of the things we can expect to see
in the successor show to game of thrones
george r martin's newest book fire and
blood has a lot of the information that
will be adapted into house of the dragon
so what i want to do is start making
videos on each chapter from fire and
blood just like i am with the chapters
from a song of ice and fire
also i do want to let you know that i
have an extra copy of fire and blood
that i will give away to one of my
subscribers
if you would like to enter the giveaway
for this book there will be a link down
below
good luck to everyone that enters shall
we begin
now we will go inside the mind of
daenerys targaryen as we see the story
unfold through her eyes in dany's very
first chapter it begins almost identical
to the way her first scene did in the
show
the chapter begins as dany's brother
viserys
holds up the gown for her inspection as
you all know viserys and illyrio have
scheduled a meeting with carl drogo and
hopes that he will marry daenerys
targaryen viserys wants to invade
westeros so that he can take back the
iron throne as well as the seven
kingdoms for house targaryen but he's
not going to be able to do this without
an army
he needs call drogo's army or in his
mind he thinks he only needs about ten
thousand dothraki screamers to get the
job done
so the chapter begins as they are
getting ready for this arrangement
viserys needs daenerys to look her best
he does not want to lose the opportunity
of gaining an army or so he thinks
the color of her gown will help bring
out the violet in her eyes
this is a gift from illyrio who also
wants things to work out in their favor
not only does he give her the dress but
he also wants her to wear some gold
and jewels of all sorts they need dany
to look like a princess
she doesn't even remember what that was
like and she thinks
maybe she had never known now although
daenerys is only 13 years old
she knows illyrio will want something in
return for doing all this for them
viserys and daenerys are broke they have
been on the run for years
and a lot of people have started to turn
their backs to them
but not illyrio he has let them live in
his house
he has let them use his servants and eat
his food
and so on and so forth he obviously will
want repaid in some way
viscera says illyrio isn't stupid
he knows how much he will benefit when
and if i ever take back the iron throne
you see illyrio is a hustler he sells
spices
gemstones dragon bone and other less
savory things
basically he could sell salt to a slug
this has allowed him to make friends all
over the free cities
and even beyond but it's also said that
illyrio would not hesitate to sell out
one of his own friends
illyrio sees viserys and daenerys as one
of his investments
it's also a bit of a gamble but i
suppose most investments are
it may seem like this is a one-sided
relationship right now
because illyrio keeps giving giving and
giving to viserys and danny
but illyrio may be able to cash out if
he can get viserys on the iron throne
daenerys does not trust him
if he can sell out one of his own
friends what would he do if he realizes
viserys
or even daenerys is a bad investment
dany briefly thinks about this and she
wants to say something to viserys about
it but she knows better than to say
something that might go against his
dream
remember illyrio is a salesman so he
knows exactly what to say to keep
viserys happy
so no matter what danny might be
thinking she doesn't want to make him
angry
or wake the dragon by now viserys has
dany wrapped around his finger he has
more or less
beaten her into submission he does this
by not only physically hurting her
but also breaking her down
psychologically nothing she does is ever
good enough for him
and whenever she does something he
doesn't like he either hurts her with
his hands
or he knocks her down by verbally
abusing her viscera says
you will not fail me tonight if you do
it will go hard for you
you do not want to wake the dragon do
you he grabs dany
and pinches her until it hurts as of
right now daenerys has no real
interest in the iron throne she would
rather be almost anywhere but here
she thinks about this as she hears the
children outside
in this moment she would gladly leave
illyrio's nice house
and give back these nice clothes so long
as she could be free to go run with the
children out in the streets
dany wants to go home but she doesn't
know where that is
dany begins to think about some of the
things that have happened in her life
thus far
and this is when we learn a lot of
information about her backstory
we find out how and why her and her
brother are on the run in essos
viserys has told her all the stories
before daenerys thinks about her brother
rhaegar fighting robert baratheon in the
bloody waters of the trident and dying
for the woman he loved
and here is our first reference of
rhaegar and lyanna's relationship
danny thinks about how rhaegar died for
the woman he loved
it doesn't say he died for his wife dany
thinks about how viserys would tell her
what happened after rhaegar died
how king's landing was sacked by robert
baratheon's dogs
the lord's lannister and stark hal
rhaegar's wife
the princess elia of dorne begged for
mercy as her and rhaegar's heir
was ripped away from her arms then
killed right before her eyes
dany thinks about how the dragon skulls
that were decorating the walls of the
throne room and the red keep
were watching as jaime lannister opened
their father's throat with a golden
sword
now danny and her brother had no choice
but to leave king's landing
otherwise they would have been killed as
well viserys was only eight years old
when they had to flee king's landing
while daenerys was still in her mother's
stomach daenerys had been born on
dragonstone
nine moons after they fled the capital
she was born during a violent summer
storm
that was so strong it destroyed the
targaryen fleet while it lay at anchor
danny's mother died while birthing her
and for that her brother viserys had
never forgiven her
this actually sounds very similar to
cersei and tyrion's relationship
viserys blames dany for their mother's
death just as cersei does tyrion
danny has no memory of dragonstone
either it wasn't long before they would
have to run again
after robert baratheon sent his brother
stannis to dragonstone to finish off the
rest of the targaryens
however thankfully for daenerys she had
a savior in sir willem derry
one night sir willem and four of his
most trusted men had broken into the
nursery and rescued dany and her brother
they set sail under the cover of
darkness for the safety of the bravosian
coast
now where they go next is where dany
makes some of her most fondest memories
she remembers how although sir willem
dary had the servants scared
he was always very nice to her he would
refer to her as the little princess
or my lady she remembers how his hands
were as soft as old leather
this is when dany thinks they were
living in braavos in a big house that
had a red door
she remembers having her own bedroom and
there was a lemon
tree right outside of her window there
are many different theories about where
this house may have actually been
many would argue that danny could not
have been in braavos because
lemons do not grow there there are even
some lines in the books that say
nothing really grows there at all unless
you have money
samwell does mention lemons growing
there but only in very specific
locations
like the gardens of the rich so it
sounds like it would make more sense if
that house with the red door were
in let's say dorne or old town instead
of braavos
but i will leave this alone for now i
may discuss it further in some of her
later chapters
viserys and dany's lives really start to
go downhill once sir willem dies
this is one of the reasons why dany
misses these moments in her life
when things were much simpler and they
were able to relax
the way dany reminisces about the red
door reminds me a lot of how arya sees
her sword needle
it's a reminder of home and this does
give them solace
this is the only thing danny wants she
wants back the childhood she had never
known
she wants the big house that has the red
door but her brother
viserys wants everything back he wants
the iron throne
and the seven kingdoms and the money and
the gold
and all the respect his last name once
demanded
now i would say her brother viserys is
getting very desperate
and unfortunately for daenerys she has
to suffer the most because of it
as soon as sir willem dies his servants
end up taking the rest of the little bit
of money viserys and danny had
then they threw them out onto the street
so now they're homeless
and broke and still on the run their
lives are a disaster
this is when they start bouncing around
from location to location
never staying anywhere for very long her
brother would not allow it
in fear of robert baratheon's assassins
finding them and killing them
you see the longer robert baratheon set
upon the iron throne
the less likely it seemed that the
targaryens would ever get it back
as the years went on viserys and dany
found it much harder to find supporters
more and more doors started to close in
their faces they had no choice but to
sell what little valuable possessions
they had left
the little bit of money they did have
was now gone viserys was now known as
the baker king
his name loses more and more respect as
each day goes by
this is why i believe viserys has become
very desperate
in his attempt to take back the seven
kingdoms in the name of house targaryen
you see daenerys had always assumed that
she would wed viserys when she came of
age
i mean this is the targaryen way of life
after all
for centuries the targaryens had married
brother to sister
since aegon the conqueror had taken his
sisters as wives
the bloodline must be kept pure viserys
said this to danny at least a thousand
times
their blood was the king's blood the
golden blood of valyria
the blood of the dragon targaryens do
not mingle their blood with that of
lesser men
but even after all that is said viserys
is about to give his sister to the
dothraki
because he doesn't gain anything by
getting married to dany as of right now
he needs an army and he needs one badly
how much longer will others wait for
viserys to become king
while him and dany stay at their house
eat their food
and have to listen to viserys cry like a
little baby every single day
daenerys is all that he has left without
her
he has nothing to gain viserys cannot
fight for what he wants on his own
he's not built like that daenerys is
their only hope
and this is when we learn something very
interesting about her
this is when we learned that it is never
too hot for a targaryen
or at least not for dany as she is
getting ready for the night
her bath is filled with hot water that
was brought up from the kitchen
the water was scalding hot but it has no
effect on danny
she does not flinch or even cry out she
knew this would happen because visceras
would always tell her
ours is the house of the dragon the fire
is in our blood this
is the foreshadowing for when daenerys
hatches her dragon eggs
after her bath they get her all dolled
up ready to be presented to call drogo
but of course viserys is never satisfied
with how danny looks therefore he has to
remind her
as soon as he sees her all dressed up he
says
she looks too skinny illyria is like
come on man
look at her look at that silver gold
hair those violet eyes
she is the blood of old valeria ian
highborn
daughter of the old king and sister to
the new king
there is no way called drogo will not
like her but
viserys is like i suppose although he
sounds like he doubts this will work
once again he will not give daenerys his
approval
she is the one making the sacrifices for
what he wants
as i said before she does not want the
iron throne
you know viserys actually reminds me of
joffrey in this chapter
viserys says he will kill robert
baratheon himself but we all know he has
never swung his sword at a man
joffrey said he would kill stannis
baratheon and rob stark
but we all know he has never swung his
sword and a man either
guess who they both did end up hurting
who did they direct their anger
and frustrations at sons and danny
instead of actually fighting on the
field of battle for themselves
they would physically and verbally abuse
13 year old little girls sons and danny
would both go on to achieve what joffrey
and viserys could never do on their own
anyways as viserys and illyrio are
having a conversation
daenerys once again thinks about how she
does not trust
anything illyrio says but viserys is
eating it up because illyrio
is selling him his dream he says
everything he knows viserys wants to
hear
he tells viserys how everyone across the
sea is crying out for their king
he says they are your people and they
love you well
men are toasting to your health while
women are sowing dragon banners and hide
them against the day of your return from
across the water
daenerys doesn't believe him while
viserys is sitting there
nodding his head in agreement alright
now let's get to the final scene of the
chapter when daenerys meets carl drogo
inside the mans the air was heavy with
the set of spices
sweet lemon and cinnamon they were
escorted across the entry
hall where a mosaic of colored glass
depicted the doom of valyria
oil burned in black iron lanterns all
along the walls
one of the eunuchs sang of their arrival
viserys of house targaryen
the third of his name he called in a
high sweet voice
king of the andals and the rhoynar and
the first men lord of the seven kingdoms
and the protector of the realm
his sister daenerys stormborn princess
of dragonstone
his honorable host elirio mopotus
magister of the free cities of pentos
the room was filled with the thracky
horselords
and sellswords and followers of velour
and the lords from the summer isles with
skin as black as ebony
daenerys looked at them all in wonder
and soon realized
she was the only woman there she was
afraid illyrio then whispered to
daenerys and her brother
those three are drogo's blood riders
over there
the man that has the green beard is the
brother to the archon of tyrosh
and the man behind him is sir jorah
mormont
now that last name got dany's attention
dany found herself
looking at sergiora mormont he was an
older man
over the age of 40 but he was still in
good shape for his age
dany notices the black bear of house
mormont embroidered on his chest
it's not often dany sees someone from
westeros
now although she has no memory of ever
living there i think she does initially
find some comfort in knowing sergiora
mormont is from her homeland
maybe this is a step in the right
direction but this
feeling soon evaporates when she sets
her eyes upon call drogo
she is frightened by the sight of him
dany wanted to run and hide
but she knew this would anger her
brother she knew this would wake the
dragon
viserys has her so beaten down mentally
physically and emotionally
she does as he says although she is very
afraid
danny notices that carl drogo was a head
taller than the tallest man in the room
yet somehow he was laid on his feet
almost graceful
he was younger than she thought he would
be no more than 30
but still twice her age his skin was the
color of copper
and his thick mustachios was bound with
gold and bronze rings
this is when viserys grabs danny by the
arm and squeezes her until it hurts
do you see his brave sweet sister
drogo's braid was black as midnight
and heavy with scented oil and there
were tiny bells in it that rang softly
as he moved
they swung well below his belt the end
of it brushing against the back of his
thighs
you see how long it is viserys said when
dothraki are defeated in combat
they cut off their braids in disgrace so
the world will know their shame
called drogo has never lost a fight he
is
aegon the dragonlord come again and you
will be his queen
danny was afraid of her brother but not
as afraid as she was of col drogo
danny does not want to marry him she
wants to go home
when viserys hears this he flies off the
handle
just like he did in this show in fact
what he says to danny is almost
identical to what he said in the show
how are we to go home sweet sister they
took her home from us
he drew her into the shadows out of
sight his fingers digging into her skin
how are we to go home he repeated
meaning king's landing in dragonstone
and all the realm they had lost dany had
only meant their rooms in illyrio's
estate
but there was no home for him there not
even the big house that had the red door
that was never home for viserys either
his fingers dug hard into her arm
demanding an answer viscera says now dry
your eyes
illyrio is bringing him over now and i
will not have him see you crying like
this
smile viserys whispered nervously as
his hand fell to the held of his sword
and stand up straight
let him see that you have breasts gods
know you have little enough as is
the chapter ends as it says daenerys
smiles
and stood up straight so as you can see
viserys beats her down
once again he physically hurts her then
he knocks her down verbally
keeping her in check this sort of sums
up the whole chapter
the relationship between daenerys and
her brother is extremely toxic
and it only gets worse as viserys
realizes his dream may never become a
reality
as his desperation intensifies his
decision-making becomes more and more
irrational
this will be his downfall daenerys on
the other hand
will go on to become one of the main
characters in the entire series
like i said earlier since we are
focusing on house targaryen in this
video
this is a good time for me to announce i
will start making videos on the fire and
blood book as well
at least once a week i will try to
release a chapter video on a song of ice
and fire
as well as a chapter video for fire and
blood this will help us all get ready
for the release of hbo's new
series house of the dragon don't forget
to enter the giveaway for your chance to
win a copy of fire and blood
that link is down below i want to thank
everyone for watching this video
and i want to thank all of you who
support my channel on patreon thank you
all so much
i will see you again very soon have a
great day
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you